bonsoir à tous
pardon les oreilles comment allez-vous
les a mais moi ça va extrêmement bien et
ça va encore mieux que d'habitude parce
qu'aujourd'hui on va tourner une vidéo
avec matsu qui à chaque fois brouillard
comme ça avant chaque début de vidéo et
je me sens mal je culpabilise et si j'ai
arrêté de travailler et de faire ce que
j'aime pour dédier ma vie à mon chien je
me suis déjà posé cette question je vais
pas vous mentir depuis j'ai un chien je
squatte un petit peu sur net les
articles qui parlent de chiens j'en ai
trouvé un qui parle de tester
l'intelligence de son chien alors faut
pas déconner c'est un truc pas du tout
officiel et tout mais cela n'empêche que
ça va quand même tester un petit peu la
jugeote de tons chair si je peux me
permettre
comme vous pouvez le voir il est
carrément opérations non mais t'es même
pas dans le champ et un bon match au
micro et opto et je me suis dit que je
devais faire ce test pour la simple et
bonne raison que je mets mon chien sur
un piédestal de malades
un peu comme un couple car bébé moche
mais qui le trouve beau quand même j'ai
ce même manque d'objectivité vis-à-vis
de mon chien je le trouve vraiment
incroyable très intelligent il est
particulier il n'est pas comme les
autres chiens mais tous les mecs ont un
chien dit ça je me suis donc dit luca a
franchement faucard voiler la face fait
un vrai test pour voir si ton chien est
vraiment celui que tu penses alors c'est
parti
c'est très simple il ya plusieurs
épreuves et selon le temps que va mettre
ton chien à résoudre l'énigme
il va gagner plus ou moins deux points
comment tester l'intelligence d'un chien
dans le domaine de la recherche sur
l'intelligence animale la seule
définition du sujet d'étude peut déjà
être difficile bien des questions de
base restent sans réponse et on se
querelle indéfiniment sur la
signification des résultats des tests
vous pouvez donc toujours affirmé que
votre chien le plus intelligent du monde
même si ses notes sont assez médiocres à
venir on peut le faire easy mecque et ça
changera pas ce que je pense de toi
ces derniers sont destinés à mesurer la
capacité à résoudre des problèmes et
l'adaptation à l'environnement alors
bonne super violent jeté une serviette
sur la tête du chien au mec ça me fait
mal au coeur
jetez là sur la tête du chien pour la
recouvrir complètement mettez le
chronomètre en route et voyez combien de
temps il faut un chien pour s'en libérer
30 secondes ou moins trois points
trente-et-une à 120 secondes deux points
ils essayent mais n'y arrive pas dans
les 120 premières secondes un point mais
à comment il peut ne pas réussir à se
débarrasser d'une serviette sais c'est
pas dur il ne cherche pas à se libérer
ce que reproche c'est génial le lien jeu
ça le dérange pas du tout qui ne
s'arrête sur sa tête et but de la
première épreuve
voici une serviette qui possède un très
joli motif tu t'assois oui
bien braves ont rêvé mais on veut pas
pense que je vais te faire c'est pour
montrer au monde que tu est très
intelligente
hu
[Musique]
oui bravo c'est de la merde comme test
un ba oui tu es bien au dessus de ça toi
tu peux résoudre des équations toi je
suis pas gagné c'est donc un trois
points pour natsuno chiba et nous en
fait ce test là est tellement easy à mes
yeux que ça m'aurait fait mal au coeur
qui comprennent pas qu'il doit se
débarrasser de la serviette deuxièmement
ka-shing friandises sous la serviette
alors vu que moi je donne pas du tout
deux flancs 10,1 à dessous je vais
mettre une croquette sur la serviette
voilà en plus c'est cool parce que les
chinois sont des chiens très intelligent
et primitif donc en fait ça va le
stimuler de devoir faire un effort pour
pouvoir manger
j'ai déjà fait des tests et quand je
stimule un peu avant qu'ils mangent ils
adorent ça en fait il a l'impression de
mériter son repas mettez le chrono met
en route et voyez combien de temps le
chiffre mais pour prendre la friandise
30 secondes ou moins 3 points à 30 et
une à 60 secondes deux points essaye
mais n'y arrive pas en espace de 60
secondes un point et n'essaye pas zéro
point monti chiba et nous vient à temps
vas-y pas croquer elle est de sous
projets croquettes
elle est là natsu et non pas natsu et
vas-y tu es intelligent terrain tempère
je décale tout je leur fait leur match
où elle est là elle elle est là mais
qu'est-ce-qui trois objets cash mais non
mais les partisans elle est là elle est
juste la natte subasic elle est là elle
est dessous
mon fils est un tricheur montre honneur
tu peux le faire mais expédie ne doit
pas mon fils tu es magnifique je sais
que tu es très intelligente a clairement
vu qu'elle était là mais j'ai
l'impression que tu as juste pas envie
de bouffer une croquette
on chiale bat
et vraiment qu'il avait pas
l'intelligence parce que la croquette
l'intéressé oh non on est donc sur du
zéro pointé
yat il ya mes preuves pour ce test vous
avez besoin d'une ouverture près du sol
que le chien peut atteindre avec ses
pattes mais non pas son museau un canapé
peut faire la faire mais vous pouvez
aussi en fabriquer une vous même à
l'aide de deux livres et larges planches
c'est vrai que tout le monde chez soi
possède une large planche
alors commençons par construire cette
cet outil du démon bouge pas mon grand
j'ai dit bouge pas je sais je
sais je sais le critique pas je sais là
dessous tu me demande ce que c'est mais
le paravent bouddha va enfin nous servir
c'est une triste fin pour mes mangas
naruto
ok on est prêt pour le test suivant
attend qu'il faut faire poser une
friandise ou une planche - coussins du
canapé pendant qu'ils vous observe
s'il réussit en l'espace de deux minutes
en servant de ses pattes c'est quatre
points en trois minutes
en servant de ses pattes trois points
s'il a échoué deux points et six se sert
uniquement de son museau un point pour
la pression j'ai l'impression ok c'est
parti la friandise et sous la planche
mort nazis j'ai mis deux sous à
l'instant tu l'as vue elle est là vous
voulez que je vous dise
je pense à a compris un truc ce tapis
est dégueulasse et je pense que ça le
stress de haut c'est la pire excuses
voit la nature je t'ai trouvé une excuse
de la prochaine fois vous tirez sinon on
est mort ok ici les dessous de son mon
grand elle est là dessous regarde va
premier accroc 4 mongrain manche la
croquette
mais ces infractions dis donc tu la veux
tu va la chercher
ok bouge pas allez vas-y voilà points
ici et là vas-y promet il est là mon
bébé vas-y banon elle est pas là haut ça
me brise le coeur
tu préfères léché des poussières de
croquettes que de faire l'effort d'aller
prendre la vraie croquettes t'es
comme ton m bézy prawna prenez mon bébé
[Musique]
ça nous fait qu'un point un petit con
bravo
bon le paravent consommation manon naoto
je suis désolé mais pour où tout est un
peu détrôner ont pas se mentir
ok il est en passe à l'épreuve suivante
mon chien le test suivant est conçu pour
éprouver la mémoire du chien et non pas
ses talents pour résoudre un problème
dans mon cas en cas de problème on a vu
qu'il est balèze
pour ce faire le chien doit comprendre
ce qui se passe mais trendy sous une
poubelle en plastique et des plus de la
trouvais ok alors ceci est une friandise
ceci est un gobelet alors un croc et
elle est où elle est où eli wallach
roquettes
[Musique]
il va faire toute la longueur comme ça
mais les mecs on va tous trouvés dans le
bureau mac fly capitaux si l' on oublie
ça ou les seins elle est où la conquête
sambre hockey bravo bravo là elle a
compris que quand il se dirige vers le
gobelet qui contient la croquette je
soulève le gobelet et il peut manger la
croquette là c'est pas un test
d'intelligence c'est juste pour qu'ils
comprennent ce qu'on attend de lui
maintenant vient le vrai test posé trois
coupelle en plastique à l'envers et au
sol et espacées d'environ 30 centimètres
mettez une friandise sous l'une d'elles
pendant que le chien vous observent fait
sortir le chien n'a pu hélas pendant
trente secondes puis revenez demande aux
chiens trouvés la friandise ça c'est
génial
un deux trois jeux mais la friandise ici
maintenant on sort on revient d'entendre
c'est bon t'es prêt mon chien tu réussi
l'épreuve
ok qu on y va alors oui la friandise où
il affronte disent bravo
[Musique]
al batha ils s'en battent les couilles
et vous il a juste vu ça il s'est dit
il est mort je peux y accéder on
va donc calculer notre score n'a donc eu
trois points la serviette 0 point la
conquête sous la serre viennent un point
à la serviette sous l'obstacle et deux
points au jeu des coupelles on est donc
un total de six points ce qui nous donne
un médor lambda est à la grand mère fils
de
la star y avait cette vidéo c'était un
très bon moment en votre compagnie j'ai
la très à l'aise dans cette position
n'est ce pas ça m'a fait trop plaisir de
faire du beau avec natsu ou j'interagis
un peu avec lui en fait dès que je
tourne il est tout le temps là à côté me
regarder ça me fait un peu de la peine
c'est sain chiba c'est un chien qui a
besoin de beaucoup de stimuler et ne
serait-ce que tourner deux heures est à
côté de lui des fois j'entends queen et
ça me brise le coeur donc je suis très
content d'avoir pu faire ça avec lui
n'hésitez pas si vous avez un animal à
jouer avec lui de cette manière là et
c'est de stimuler intellectuellement
chèque pour les chats il ya des jeux
aussi intellectuels hommes tuent mais
les croquettes à certains endroits ils
doivent comprendre comment choper la
croquette j'ai failli jumbo ils s'en
battent et les coups il a perdu 20 kilos
mais c'est cool c'est cool de travailler
avec eux de cette manière là on doit
l'acheter content et ça m'a donné envie
de faire plus souvent vraiment aller au
maximum de bisous à vous et à vos
animaux ou à vos parents que si vous
n'avez pas d'animaux a très vite dans
une prochaine vidéo par des vous bien et
de natsu s'endort et relais ce qui veut
dire que ces petites épreuves l'ont
vraiment stimulé il est fatigué
carrément bon allez je salue faut que je
pourrais vous parler de match où pendant
huit mois lui c'est toute ma vie
maintenant mais il faut mettre fin cette
vidéo aller
[Musique]